au nom de pandémie au nom de profonds
bouleversements au nom de désinformation
et depuis le début tout et son contraire
a été dit sur l'origine du virus
responsable de la cobi 19 le sera ce kof
deux des vérités des hypothèses encore
en suspens et beaucoup beaucoup de
désinformation
non cette femme mange en chauve souris
n'est pas responsable de la pandémie
non il n'existe aucun lien entre la 5g
et le nouveau coronavirus non la chine
n'a pas frôlé le coronavirus d'un
laboratoire canadien non chercheurs de
harvard n'a pas fabriqué et vendu le
corps un avis russe à la chine
non le corps n'avait russe n'a pas été
créée à partir du vih ces quelques
faussetés ne sont que la pointe de
l'iceberg dans un océan d'infos dès mi
mai un an plus tard où en sont les
connaissances scientifiques sur
l'origine de ce virus responsable de
près de 3 millions de décès à travers le
monde marie-pierre alors 3 millions ou
presque de décès plus tard à tout ce qui
concerne cette pandémie l'un fait
énormément jaser depuis le mois de mars
dernier
mais aujourd'hui la un an plus tard on
se pose la question fondamentale qu'est
ce qu'on sait sur le régime de la copie
19 oui parce que quand on se pose la
question où quand comment pourquoi cette
pandémie là a commencé mais on a des
éléments d'information beaucoup de
désinformation à combattre aussi mais ya
pas grand-chose de coulées dans le béton
bon l'hypothèse la plus vraisemblable
c'est que ce virus là a une origine
animale comme 60 % des maladies
infectieuses et c'est fort probablement
au sait pas précisément le commun
maillaud
il y aurait une chauve souris qui
auraient été impliquées dans le
processus
à quelque part pourquoi une chauve
souris parce qu'on sait déjà qu'elle il
les chaussures en général son réservoir
de milliers de coronavirus différents et
les coronavirus le plus semblable
génétiquement au nôtre c'est chez la
chauve souris qu'on l'a identifié il
96 % identique mais il lui manque quand
même quelque chose d'important pour
réussir à ce rang à se transmettre entre
les humains comme la co vide le fait
c'est un tout petit bout de génomes qui
code pour la fameuse protéine spike et
de façon plus imagée on pourrait dire
qui lui manque qu'une clé pour entrer
dans nos cellules
il aurait pu se procurer la clé en
séjournant dans les cellules d'une autre
espèce animale donc un autre
intermédiaire il ya plusieurs espèces
suspectes sur la liste mais on n'a pas
encore formellement identifié lequel oui
la traque la recherche se poursuit
encore et toujours mais ce qui semblait
assez évident déjà au début marie-pierre
c'est que le virus serait franchi la
barrière entre cet animal mystérieux et
l'humain dans l'immense marché de one où
étaient vendus plusieurs animaux vivants
oui au départ ce marché là c'était
vraiment l'endroit tout désigné
justement à cause la proximité des
clients avec toutes sortes d'espèces
d'animaux vivants il ya des échantillons
qui ont été prélevé des échantillons
d'animaux de produits animaux qui
étaient vendus là et ils étaient tous
négatifs
donc aujourd'hui on considère le marché
peut-être plus comme un amplificateur
quelques comme le déclencheur en tant
que tel et dans toute cette séquence la
marie pierre par contre si on veut
situer dans le temps ce passage de
l'animal à l'humain
il ya quand même un consensus dans la
mesure où on sait que les tous premiers
cas remontent à quoi décembre 2010 9
environ
oui les premiers cas officiel en tout
cas déclarés par la chine
maintenant on rapporte peut-être y
aurait eu des cas en novembre ou même
avant parce qu'en fait il ya plusieurs
virologues qui sont persuadés que les
premiers humains infectés l'aurait été
peut-être même il ya plusieurs années
ah ouais ouais parce que en fait quand
un virus fait le saut comme ça d'une
espèce à une autre
ça lui prend un certain temps pour
si on veut s'adapter à son nouvel hôte
ce qui fait que souvent les virus tout
de suite après avoir franchi cette
barrière là ils sont pas très très très
contagieux et tu disais tantôt ce qui ce
qui semble plus vraisemblable le
scénario le plus vraisemblable mais
c'est que ce mystérieux patient zéro
qu'on connaît pas a été infecté par un
animal mais d'autres scénarios beaucoup
circulé dont celui du virus conçu en
laboratoire et dans ce qui est devenu un
tout premier décryptage pandémique en
janvier dernier en janvier 2020 on
prétendait même qu'il avait été volé
dans un laboratoire milk de
microbiologie de winnipeg par deux
espions chinois sont au moins
marie-pierre on peut dire que c'est faux
oui le scénario de la fabrication du
virus en laboratoire on peut dire qui
est complètement écartée par la
communauté scientifique
il ya vraiment rien n'y a pas de
signature d'altération ou de
manipulation on à faire un génome tout
ce qu'il ya de plus banal qui est le
fruit de mutation et de la sélection
naturelle
par contre un scénario qu'on peut pas
complètement écarter
c'est celui de l'accident de laboratoire
où le virus se seraient échappées puis
même à première vue il ya quand même une
coïncidence assez troublante c'est que
haouran ya un institut de virologie qui
héberge une pièce importante collection
de coronavirus de chauves souris
donc c'est facile d'imaginer quelqu'un
qui travaille là qui manipule le muscle
se fait contaminée et qui en
franchissant les portes du laboratoire
offre un tout nouveau terrain de jeu à
un virus c'est facile à imaginer
maintenant les scientifiques d'une
mission de l'om est qu'ils se sont
rendus sur place juste scénario-là peu
plausible
ils ont rencontré les chercheurs de
l'institut ont discuté ouvertement
semble-t-il de ces questions là avec eux
et vraiment il semblerait que ils seront
testés régulièrement que les mesures de
sécurité sont très strictes
bref ces chercheurs l'ont trouvé aucun
indice
le qui seraient susceptibles de soulever
des doutes et aussi d'autres chercheurs
indépendants disent que si on avait soit
découvert ou manipuler ce virus-là en
laboratoire avant la pandémie
ça aurait fait l'objet d'une publication
scientifique
on en aurait parlé dans le milieu et
c'est pas du tout le cas
peut-être en terminant insisté à quel
point c'est important de découvrir
l'origine de ce virus n'est pas
seulement une petite curiosité
scientifique annonce fondamentale ou une
occasion de pointer des coupables du
doigt là c'est vraiment c'est que ça
nous donne des munitions pour être en
mesure par exemple d'éviter l'émergence
d'un éventuel sera sco v3
s'ils ont réussi à identifier par
exemple l'espèce animale qui a favorisé
la transmission à l'humain on pourrait
entre autres interdire l'élevage de
cette espèce là où en tout cas limités
les interactions avec elle la clé du
mystère se trouve en chine un pays où le
gouvernement central maintien d'une
solide emprise sur l'information qui
circule à propos de l'accord et 19
depuis le début de la pandémie l'eau à
metz les journalistes et les
gouvernements étrangers se sont souvent
buté à l'opacité du régime
annick bureaud en sait quelque chose
elle était aux premières loges au moment
où tout a commencé
l'ex correspondante de radio canada ap
key est maintenant de retour à montréal
prête pas partager ses constants
[Musique]
avec bureaux bonjour et bienvenue aux
décrypteurs merci alexis enfin j'ai la
chance de parler aux décrypteurs ont
voulu en savoir plus sur sa couverture
des événements en chine pendant la
pandémie
qu'est ce que tu a observé et comment
s'est manifestée d'opacité du régime
on est arrivé n'est janvier 2020 et arue
dans un espèce de flou qui régnait un
fou je dirais alexis un mélange entre
des rumeurs des photos qui circulait sur
les réseaux sociaux des médecins qui
parlait d'un mystérieux virus en truck
échanger leurs qui dit que dans les
couloirs à l'hôpital dans leur centre
médical dans leurs cliniques qui voyait
apparaître ce mystérieux virus
et de l'autre côté il y avait des
démentis officiels sur la propagation
même de la maladie
le 20 janvier le président jean ping a
décrété lundi la première fois qu'il a
parlé de l'épidémie comme tel il
décrypte une espèce de mobilisation
générale en tant que la vie et la santé
des citoyens de la priorité est le
maintien espèce de guerre du peuple
contre le diable je crois que c'était
une expression qu'il avait utilisé ses
séides de résumer et se contentait mais
c'était une période assez spéciale et
évoqué donc les réseaux sociaux là bas
c'est surtout un beau l'équivalent
chinois de twitter dont il est question
et c'est sur ce réseau là qu'on circule
et la plupart des images de ce qui se
tramait sur le terrain avec des lanceurs
d'alert qui ont commencé à tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé et qui en ont payé le
prix on sait qu'il ya une journaliste
citoyenne qui a été condamné à la prison
plusieurs années de prison s'il ya
quelques semaines accusés d'avoir
propagé de fausses rumeurs pour sa
couverture de la coved de 19 mais après
tout on parle de lanceurs dallaire qui
avait des médecins de roura le docteur
li nian et qui a été contaminé en
soignant une une de ses clients il est
tombé malade et le décide et bombay
s'est assise bay et dire ce qu'il en est
et il le dit aussi qu'il fallait
propager il fallait donner la place à
plus de bois possibles divergences qui
se passait et il est mort lui le 7
février de cette maladie là et se savait
créer un courant d'indignation dans les
réseaux sociaux liu xiang qui fera 6 et
2 du martyr a été réhabilité plus tard
avec les médecins quand la chaîne décidé
de rendre hommage au travail et de la
santé en présentant aussi l1 victoire
contre le canadien et tout ça nous mène
à la visite récente en chine d'une
équipe d'experts de la msa nique pour
essayer de comprendre l'origine du virus
on attend un rapport là dessus la
semaine prochaine à qu'on doit
s'attendre
déjà le fait que l' oms soit rendue plus
d'un an après le début de l'épidémie sur
les lieux même ça posait déjà des
questions la zone du marché
quittons quart de tous les soupçons
avaient été vraiment cédé à quel point
tout ce qu'il y avait là dedans a été
conservée comme preuve dans quelles
conditions c'est la question qu'on peut
se poser avec quoi ont pu travailler
élire inspecteurs de l'om est et bien
c'est la grande question je crois déjà
qui le suivait à des questions et pas
mal d'incertitudes au sujet du bilan qui
pourrait ou enfin du rapport pourrait
déposer avant même de quitter la chine
est donc je sais pas si on bat jamais
savoir quelle est la source même de ceux
de ce coronavirus qui est bouleversée
tellement de vies et en commençant par
la chine c'est une bonne question
voilà alors qu'on a tant besoin
d'éclaircissements et de réponses face à
cette crise
annick merci nous avoir parlé à une
prochaine
salut plaisir partagé je suis très
heureuse de parler ici